[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur j'ai une question indiscrète
pour vous êtes vous un bon amant qu'en
est il de vos prouesses ou lis les
miennes à se porter très bien surtout au
début
les débuts à la lune de miel
tout est simple on se regarde un petit
clin d'oeil on se retrouve au lit à la
belle époque tu la vois plusieurs
sourires il ya quelques années je
réalise pourtant que nos débuts sont
devenus routine elle est souvent est
disposée et finis les petits clins
d'oeil ça me décourage pas je me dis
elle a simplement besoin d'un peu de
romance et de nouveautés d'abord
j'attends de varier les angles les
approches les positions les musées les
éclairages puis j'ajoute des fleurs des
restos chocolat dans ce massage ci
dessous des jeux de rôle d'y jouer
dupuis banque totale quoi hélas malgré
toute la bonne volonté
rien ne dit que je pense avoir trouvé la
recette parfaite qui marche à tous les
soirs ça marche plus et là je commence à
croire qu'elle a un problème de libido
sorbonne quelque chose comme ça un soir
dans la cuisine elle m'annonce chérie je
veux réaliser un rêve d'enfance je pars
seul en australie ok trois semaines car
moi même à moi de tenir la maison de
m'occuper des enfants et de tout le
reste je m'encourage en me disant qu
après tant d'efforts j'aurais sûrement
droit à une belle récompense donc trois
semaines plus tard la voilà de retour il
à messieurs imaginer la pression dans
les tuyauteries saint frégant comme un
étalon en route fin prêt pour ma
récompense il le coup de théâtre
à peine arrivé il me dit j'ai fait la
paix avec moi même je suis prête à me
priver de sexe plutôt que de continuer à
me faire secouer comme un sac de pommes
de terre
et elle ajoute ma décision est ferme et
je suis prête à te quitter sur de faux
et puis elle notant son sac à dos de
voyage puis il me dit voici le fardeau
de porter seuls la responsabilité de
notre vie sexuelle
j'en ai bien fini de toute cette
culpabilité
à toi de le porter maintenant
aujourd'hui ça me fait rire avec le
recul je trouve qu'elle a eu beaucoup de
courage je me dis tout ça à ce moment là
sur le coup par contre ça fait mal
mon premier réflexe partir loin pour
trouver enfin la bonne personne mais
j'ai fait ce sont plusieurs fois dans ma
vie
puis toujours avec le même résultat
comme un ours
je me réfugie dans la caverne pour
passer l'hiver il prend soin de mon ego
ou prétend j'en ressors
frappé par une idée de génie ce n'est
pas à moins qu'elle dit non c'était ce
que je lui propose en guise de sexualité
donc si je change l'offre la demande va
revenir le soir venu dans la cuisine
là où chez nous les choses se disent
chérie je suis prêt à changer
dis moi ce que tu as besoin comme
sexualité et là je vais visiblement
contrarié qui me dit je sais pas je
devrais me sentir
je sera pas demain finalement elle
ajoute j'ai besoin de tendresse de
calais de sentir une connexion entre
nous car way
ok ok ok j'adore les défis je me lance
alors dans une quête pour trouver la
recette de la connexion des écoles
évidemment je cherche partout je ne
trouve rien de nouveau donc je fini par
demander à mes potos bistrot imaginez la
scène
au bistrot montvert ligue 1 ma femme me
demande plus de connexion du coeur
qu'est ce que vous me conseillez vous
recommencez chacun regarde sauveur
silence radio
il y en a qu as tu essayé les fleurs les
restos le chocolat la danse les massages
les p'tits dessous et tout le reste
bref rien de nouveau un peu découragé je
retourne vers ma femme et je lui demande
chérie c'est quoi dans la recette pour
connecter nos coeurs et je l'avoué me
souriant me contrarier kindy devinez
quoi
je sais pas
c'est vrai ça c'est
mais là elle me regarde dans les yeux et
elle dit trouve-t-on propre chambre et
j'ai confiance en toi ça me touche comme
une reine avec son chevalier je la sens
d'investir d'une mission sacrée
bien des années plus tard voici ce que
j'ai écrit pour le remercie aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'aimerais te north et
d'avoir eu le courage de nommer semble
imposer ce héros que tu voyais en moi
pour être certain j'ai eu à faire face à
mes parents à mes émotions refoulées
pour toucher enfin la vraie puissance
celle qui rime avec présence celle qui
se conjugue en douceur cette délicieuse
force tranquille
merci à toi merci à toutes les femmes
qui osent encore rêver contre vents et
marées de preux chevaliers de
troubadours de ciel étoilé
bon j'avais une mission mais à l'époque
j'avais pas où chercher
finalement j'ai trouvé par hasard s'ils
étaient les enfants jouent dehors après
après le repas du soir il nous sommes ou
dans les cuisines là où les choses se
disent c'est là qu'elle commence à me
raconter sa journée
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
faites vous aussi mesdames
oui généralement pour nous ça se passe
très mal
chaque fois qu'elle me parle de ses
problèmes
je propose une solution
et variablement elle finit par se fâcher
fatigué par son manque de bonne foi je
me dis ce soir là qu'elle se débrouille
tout seul je les compte donc s'en est
remis à ma grande surprise nous pensons
un super maman presque magique
je sens une complicité retrouvée se
prolonger toute la soirée jusque dans le
clip et je comprends qu'il vient de se
passer quelque chose de capital note à
moi-même les coudes silencieuse favorise
connexion d'écart
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour je m'efforce de lui offrir
ma présence nous peaufinons ensemble
méthodes cas c'est vraiment un travail
d'équipé
voici quelques observations elle doit
assumer sa beauté et rayonnant il offrir
le commérage n'est pas bon recevoir
je dois cesser de faire pour m'ouvrir et
la recevoir cinq conditions ce moment
nous sort de nos têtes
peu à peu le souriant sans raison tandis
que le temps c'est face à la longue je
sens vraiment une chaleur du mouvement
dans ma poitrine quelque chose qui
sommeille en moi et surtout le plus beau
cadeau
je la trouve de plus en plus belle comme
au début comme si de nouveaux j'arrive à
la voir avec d'autres yeux du corps je
pousse encore plus loin
je réalise qu un trouveur que je réalise
que mon cas sauf plus facilement si
j'espère profondément comme si je
voulais la faire rentrer tout entière
dans mon coeur messieurs essayons
ensemble
prenez un instant pour visualiser la
dame de vos pensées
puis plonger votre regard intérieur
dans votre cas et là on nous paie pour
le faire ensemble en nous et on espère
profondément c'est bon ak
autre découverte extraordinaire ça me
donne de l'énergie
moi qui avais l'impression de donner
beaucoup de recevoir points je réalise
qu être ouvert sans donner de conseils
sans chercher à vos raisons bref est
juste présent pour elle ça me donne de
l'énergie
ouvrez me permet de capter le plein
rayonnement de sa beauté sa charge mon
cas comme un panneau salah mais ce
qu'est ce que ça vous fait savoir que
vous avez peut-être vous aussi un quart
panneaux solaires à la langue de vie
retrouve de la fluidité
faire l'amour avec les quarts à
connecter c'est vraiment mieux
nous le faisons d'ailleurs un plus
ouvert mais c'est encore difficile
d'harmoniser nos désirs ouais t'es le
scout toujours prêt
et pas toujours je lui demande souvent
comment elle va être touchée car et
c'est toujours elle me répond devinez
quoi
je sais pas
c'est des vrais sentir mais c'est devenu
une blague entre nous et elle
m'encourage souvent disant fais toi
confiance
un dédain tu sais mais bon je me sens
parfois vraiment maladroit
un jour je parle de sexe avec un ami et
subitement il me dit il il se livre
faire l'amour de manière divine de bari
langues
il me dit toutes les femmes que je
connais rêve d'essayer sur un vélo donc
je le lit d'une traite et là ça fait roi
comme un électrochoc
dès le premier chapitre je comprends que
ma façon de faire l'amour comme tout le
monde est dysfonctionnel pourquoi parce
que cette façon mais c'est bardé
lentement mais sûrement
c'est l'histoire de ma vie pourquoi
faire l'amour ce n'est plus pauvres je
voudrais faire jouer je découvre que nos
corps ont plutôt besoin de laisser
circuler l'amour en trop
l'important n'est plus tellement de
s'exciter non car cela augmente le
stress
il faut plutôt se détendre et passer du
temps de qualité l'inde
l'autre moyenne nationale 5,4 minutes
selon google
c'est la durée moyenne d'une relation
sexuelle et là j'apprends que c'est très
en dessous de nos besoins réels
ils font plutôt consacrer des heures à
chaque semaine il est même question de
se fixer des rendez-vous et whaou
mon désir est enfin bon pour la santé
je comprends aussi que ça va demander
tout un travail d équipe déjà d'aller
lui en parler ça ne fait pas voici
comment ça se passe je m'approche chéri
voici le livre qui va changer nos vies
et là elle me regarde
agacée elle décide quand même de lire le
livre
merci à son intuition féminine après sa
lecture elle revient vers moi rien et
elle me dit ah je pensais est folle de
croix tout seul et je réalise que nous
sommes au moins deux avec l'auteur et
même trop avec toi pourquoi faire
l'amour ce n'est plus pour courir vers
l'orgasme
nous voulons maintenant sortir de
l'autoroute pour découvrir les routes de
campagne
et là nous commençons à pratiquer les
trois r
quelqu'un a une idée trois verbes qui
commence par la lettre r
à ralentir oui comment cela s'est passé
mais seulement en présent les 4 as tu
respires et ouais exacte et recenser et
recommencer
ces trois clics vous êtes vraiment ces
quatre clés nous est vraiment sortir de
la moyenne nationale et de la
performance
quel fardeau de déposer ce quel
soulagement de déposer ce fardeau
plus besoin d'être superman je peux
enfin suivre un nouveau tempo
pourquoi faire l'amour
une nouvelle réponse en forme dans le
silence de mon coeur pour connecter avec
elle pour être dans une intimité si
profond qu'il n'est plus de mots pour le
décrire
par la grâce ses connexions prolongée de
toutes ces heures passées avec elle en
elle je découvrais la joie d'être en
communion au fil de toutes ces années
passées à explorer ce puissant carte
j'ai découvert qu'il existait un tel un
endroit magique dans son ventre de femme
une porte ouverte sur l'infini c'est par
là que la femme magicienne arrive à
faire passer dans notre monde des armes
des enfants émerveillés j'ai découvert
que cette porte vous pouvez aussi
s'ouvrir
quand je lui fais l'amour lentement
longtemps comme un homme c'est la farine
puis tivement et c'est par cette porte
ouverte qui est la femme magicienne
arrive à faire passer dans notre morne
flow d'amour qui va toujours
s'élargissant cet endroit béni je sais
dans mon ventre donne et ce paradis
perdu que je cherche depuis toujours
comme un chevalier j'étais en quête d'un
saint graal qui n'existe qu'en
pourquoi faire l'amour parce que dans
notre monde où leur manque de tout
chaque couple possédant lui ce pouvoir
immense de mettre fin à la faim d'entrer
dans un espace d'abondance où l'amour
coule à flot ou le coeur et le sexe ou
la et la faim sont enfin réconciliés
[Applaudissements]